Ariana is with us in Miami hey Ariana
how are you hey guys how's everything
better than I deserve
how can I help my question is pretty
much um I have baby step number one with
thousand dollars in emergency fund
laughter I started doing my budget and
as far as like what I owe and all my
balances I found out that the amount
that I owe is more than my budget so
your monthly payments is more than your
income correct okay and that's based on
what how much do you make a month I make
about thirty two hundred okay is that
your take-home pay or your total that's
take-home pay okay and do you have do
you have retirement coming out of that
um I actually paused it after reading
your book good okay so after pausing it
you have thirty two hundred correct and
it's sometimes very based off my income
but gotcha how much how much is your
rent uh my rent is about 350 because I
do live with my parents okay
and so you pay them three hundred fifty
dollars a month right okay and is that
room and board pretty much yeah I paid
my father's insurance as a way to help
out so that I'm not living rent-free
okay and how much is that that's what my
con his 306 okay and how much is your
car payment our payment is 349 okay and
what other debts do you have I just you
know phone bills food and groceries gas
my essentials when I did the whole
budget it was about 1800s and then the
rest would be going towards paying that
off when I did you have any debt other
than your car loan debt and credit card
debt yes okay that's what I'm asking how
much do you owe on your student loans
student loans it's about 30
oh I'm credit card 30000 and credit
cards is about I want to say it's about
15,000 okay and do you have the total of
those two payments yes how much it's
about actually I'll pull it up right now
we're just yeah your credit card payment
are your student loan payment I think
the total I want to say if all here it
is one thousand six hundred and eighty
three dollars for both of those right
okay all right cool
all right let's see ah all right so I'm
thinking um credit card payments are
really really high here and how much do
you owe on your car ah luckily I have
only all about four thousand son okay so
that's being knocked down real quick
then what is it worth what's it worth um
it's worth about 2,500 oh wow okay so
why do you have such a ridiculous
payment on it your payment earning
incident I had bad credit at the time
okay so you got a real high interest
rate on that as well yeah mm-hmm all
right so uh well you said your are your
parents furnishing you food or not no
I'm purchasing my own food okay some
that's what I meant by room and board
okay so you buy your own food you live
with them and and so here's what I would
do I'd go back through that budget and
cut out anything that you're spending on
you I mean you don't need to be eating
out at all and you don't need a bunch of
entertainment at all the first thing you
got to do is take care of food shelter
clothing transportation and utilities so
the first thing you got to do is take
care of your car and your rent and the
insurance that you promised to pay your
dad which is kind of part of the rent
but if you consider those two things you
have a fairly high rent payment I mean
if you're you know you're kind of a
roommate of sorts and you know roommates
don't usually have a
650 dollar payment you know so you may
want to think about that and go you know
is this really a great deal to live with
them I don't know if it is or not it
might be a better deal to have a
roommate live somewhere else you just
have to look at where you're living and
what the apartment would cost and that
kind of stuff
so that's something to think about
because you got 656 bucks going out for
basically for rent because you're paying
the insurance and the rent check both
right right and you wouldn't be paying
his insurance if you didn't live there
right right so it's kind of it's a type
of rent so that the car payments going
away soon how many hours a week are you
working about 43 that's good okay so one
thing we can do is pick up the extra job
whether it's waiting tables are driving
uber I don't care what it is but
whatever you can do to pick up some heck
because if you picked up a thousand
bucks a month it'll change your life and
II think you know so if you work like
crazy between Christmas you know and you
knock the car the rest of the way out
all of the sudden this thing starts to
free up and and of course you cut out
anything in the budget that's that's
knocking you around as far as external
spending and so forth I mean you do have
a tight budget I'm not questioning that
you don't have a lot of wiggle room in
this with the numbers you've given me
you may have to call the student loans
and do a hardship deferral until after
the first of the year and just where you
don't do a payment to them until after
January so that you can get squared
around and get this budget moving and
get this car paid off and then that will
give you room to really start pounding
on the credit cards and start cleaning
those off because those are going to be
your smallest debts once the car is gone
and because they're individual credit
cards I assume not 115 thousand dollars
right now so you're going to let them go
should I let them go late in the
meantime if you cannot wait other right
now yeah I wouldn't if you can keep from
it I wouldn't let anything go live and
keep from it but your first goal is food
shelter clothing transportation and
utilities your first goals take care of
you then your next goal is to pay
payments and if you put the student
loans on hardship deferral and you
tighten up your budget I think you can
make the credit card payments okay and I
shouldn't touch my emergency fund at all
how much is in it a thousand
no it's this is not an emergency this
cashflow problem you do all of that and
pick up an extra job you're going to
turn this around and by this time next
year you're going to have knocked a real
hole in this Oh
twelve months from now you're gonna be
living a completely different life
you'll be heading the right way you are
doing really good stuff how old are you
I'm 25 cool what do you do for a living
I work in sales good for you okay cool
well if you will do all of that I think
this will work for you and I want you to
go through our class Financial Peace
University have you heard of it I have
heard of it yet okay have you been
through no I haven't purchased it okay
would you like to go through as my guest
of course absolutely I want you to go
through I'm going to put you on hold
Kelly's going to pick you up and sign
you up and then when you get moving if
you got any questions as you're going
along you call me because this is tight
and I know you're scared but this this
will work you can do this you got this
and um you know you're gonna have to
look at the rent thing you're going to
look at the extra job thing you have to
tighten the budget down and put this to
put the student loans on hardship
deferral and I think you can turn it
around then and buy after the first year
you're going to start really pounding on
this stuff by this time next year you
should have those credit cards and your
car gone and be left with only the
student loans to work on but you're
going to you know it's going to be a
tough two two-and-a-half years ahead of
you and you could be completely debt
free that's what I'm seeing right here
but this is going to be hard
I mean you maybe maybe it's a solid
three years really if you don't get your
income up dramatically but if you're in
sales that's the other thing maybe you
get thing maybe the sales start
turnaround you get your income up so
this is good you can do this hold on
Kelly will pick up and we'll get you
signed up for Financial Peace University
and take care of you hey guys Rachael
Cruz here hope you enjoyed that video
from the Dave Ramsey show if you want to
watch another great video check out my
video three things you should consider
renting right over here or click the
link in the description below
you